ash has done this multiple times in the  relationship holding things back and not  telling me the full situation it's a  huge example of why I have concerns  about what could happen if he came to  America with a son so let's say ash and  I really want to pursue things ash has  expressed that he wants to come to  America as soon as possible with Taj has  he talked to you about like how that  situation would work he came out with  the question one day I really had to  digest it it took and I'm still  digesting and I'm still processing  because I said I feel deeply upset about  it  Tasha is my world Taj is my will I  cannot even conceive infer them being in  a different kind I just can't right  [Music]